invité de ce journal et c'est un
privilège car il se fait rare sur les
plateaux de télévision fabrice luchini
bonsoir l'un des trois interprètes de
l'une des pièces les plus drôles et les
plus subtils jamais créé à paris je le
pense
art de yasmina reza pour résumer
l'intrigué très rapidement l achat par
serge c'est-à-dire fabrice luchini à
dermatologue fortune et d'un tableau
tout blanc pour la somme de 200 mille
francs
elle va provoquer une sorte de scène de
ménage dévastatrice avec ses deux
meilleurs amis marc pierre vaneck et
yvan pierre arditi avant de discuter
tout de suite un petit extrait serge
vient de s'acheter un tableau enfin bon
beau blanc blanc blanc représente pas
une toile d'environ un mètre soixante
sur un mètre vingt fond blanc
entièrement blanc en diagonale de fines
rayures transversale blanche
tu vois et peut-être une ligne
horizontale blanche
en complément vers le bas objectivement
il n'est pas blanc il a un fond blanc
avec toute une peinture dans les grilles
ya même du rouge veut dire qu'il est
très pâle il serait blanc il me plairait
pas marc le voit blanc c'est sa limite
marc le voit blanc parce qu'il s'est
enferré dans l'idée qu'il était blanc
yvan non yvan voit qu'il n'est pas blanc
marque peut penser ce qu'il veut je
m'emmerde
voilà alors c'était un tournage pour
nous